apple vient de faire sa première
conférence du mois de septembre jeudi
deux premières parce que je pense qu'on
aura d'autres aujourd'hui sont vraiment
concentrés sur l'apple l'ouest et sur
les ipad ça y est je pense qu'ils ont
renouvelé tous les ipad de l'année 2020
sans apparaît un peu plus tard des ipad
ou qu'on regardera ça je vais pas vous
vous abonniez d'ailleurs c'est pas déjà
fait en créant son petit bouton rouge
ici comme ça vous saurez tout des qu'on
parlera des prochains produits d'apple
et notamment de l'ipad et des iphone un
peu plus tard qu'aujourd'hui on vraiment
parler de l'apple watch series 6 la
toute nouvelle montre alors moi c'est
pas là si ce que je poignet vous en
douterez ait pas encore arrivé à moi
c'est la 4 à 4 d'abord je sais pas la
5e' si apple offre un très gros focus
sur la santé c'est vrai que les montres
connectés et notamment l'appel watch on
la connaît pour la partie sport en
disant effectivement on fait beaucoup de
sport elle vous traquent votre rythme
cardiaque elle vous dit tout sur votre
activité
ça c'est la partie émergée de l'iceberg
et on le voir déjà depuis plusieurs
années apple fait un gros focus sur la
santé parce que c'est un point qui est
extrêmement importante sur tout ce que
permet de faire en plus cet outil on l'a
vu notamment il faut que c'était il ya
deux ans avec l'électro cardiogramme
qu'on peut faire avec sa montre il a
fallu un peu de temps pour que la mise à
jour arrive jusqu'à nous mais on peut le
faire avec ça c'est vraiment bien il ya
le suivi du rythme cardiaque et là ils
vont encore plus loin avec le calcul du
taux d'oxygène dans le sang alors vous
dirai pour monsieur et madame tout le
monde
à quoi vous servir de savoir le taux
d'oxygène que vous avez dans le sens
d'un instant t eh bien on va parler ici
de prévention à la santé on va parler
aussi de personnes qui ont des problèmes
cardiaques à des gens qui ont des
problèmes aussi d'hypertension on va
pouvoir parler à tous ces gens là et
leur donner un outil de mesure quotidien
transparent invisible on savoir s'ils
ont des risques à un instant t pour leur
santé et ça c'est vraiment bien et c'est
un outil qui est vraiment intéressant
dans ce sens là alors on va se dire
comment est ce que maman tu vas réussir
à calculer le taux d'oxygène dans le
sang parce qu'effectivement elle n'a pas
accès à vos veines enfin n'a pas accès
wi non en fait elle va émettre des
lumières il ya de l'infrarouge elle
aimait également des lumières se
permettra de voir à travers vos veines
devant la couleur de votre sang et de
voir vos globules rouges et voir s'ils
sont chargés d'oxygène alors après le
pont de détails je le connais pas mais
en tout cas l'idée elle est là donc
apple va vraiment chercher ces personnes
là les personnes qui effectivement ont
des besoins de santé et ça leur permet
d'ouvrir toujours plus la cible alors
derrière toutes les questions bien-être
si par exemple vous n'avez pas
aujourd'hui de pathologies
cardiovasculaires
vous vous dites ça va pas forcément
m'intéressait et si à côté de ça et bien
vous n'êtes pas non plus un grand
sportif ça pas forcément venir vous
intéressez néanmoins ces noms qui est
connecté qui va vous permettre de faire
tout plein de choses gestion de votre
agenda de vos contacts passer des appels
le gp
je vous en passe et des meilleures on a
donc un objet qui est hyper complet et
qui fait tout ce qu'on attend d'une
montre et même bien plus et c'est en ça
que c'est vraiment intéressant et voir
de quelle manière apple innove pour
proposer de nouvelles solutions
il ya aussi toute la question du sommeil
vous allez pouvoir venir suivre votre
sommeil alors ça c'est un peu moi mon
truc moi j'ai besoin de dormir sans
montre donc la nuit je l'enlève
donc je vais pas venir traquer mon
sommeil d'ailleurs dit moi si vous
pourriez faire marquer moi ça en bas en
commentaire vous avez aussi une
fonctionnalité qui est intéressante qui
était présentée lors de leurs qui note
au mois de juin c'est la durée de lavage
des mains vingt secondes pour bien laver
vos mains vous avez un petit compteur
bon ok bien côté un peu gadget c'est
pratique c'est bien et c'est surtout
s'inscrit dans l'air du temps par
rapport à l'épidémie coronavirus
derrière vous avez toute nouvelle puce
c'est la puce est sis d'apple qu'ils
annoncent comme étant 20 % plus rapide
que la génération précédente et une non
qui permettra d'avoir de nouveau design
au point de vue logiciel ils appellent
ça le white space c'est tout simplement
le cadran de votre montre de toujours
plus personnalisé avec vos mémos dit
avec des drapeaux avec un côté également
artistique et ce qui est intéressant
c'est ce qu'ils appellent également le
solo loupe alors le solo loupé c'est
votre bracelet ça c'est un bracelet
traditionnel d'apple watch vraiment
curieux de voir parce qu'en fait le seul
loupe il est en une seule et même parti
il est fermé il ya plusieurs couleurs il
ya plusieurs tailles
en gros vous mettez votre montre vous
les cartes et vous glissez votre main et
elle vient se mettre directement autour
de votre podium ça sera déjà bien
pour un point un point essentiel c'est
que à la différence voiliers de ce petit
bras c'est là où je veux glisser mon
parti de silicone d'intérieur où je
m'arrache à chaque fois les poils qui
croyez moi que c'est une séance de pas
de torture mais c'est vraiment pas y
aller au musée de lever pour ne pas me
faire une épilation complète à chaque
fois et bien vous n'aurez plus à le
faire vous prenez vous mettez autour de
votre panier ça détend twitter vraiment
bien pensé il ya un design qui étaient
revus notamment au niveau des bracelets
nike au niveau des bracelets hermès dont
bon donc il ya des mises à jour qui sont
faites un lien notre banque est
intéressant il appelle ça le fait
glisser dans le family c'est top c'est
vous êtes parrot moi je suis parent par
exemple il y est un peu petit
aujourd'hui mais il va grandir dans les
années à venir je pourrais donner une
apple watch je vais pouvoir activer son
applewhite à partir de mon iphone lui
n'aura pas d'iphone il lui faut une
montre par contre avec une petite carte
sim et je pourrais savoir où il est à un
instant t jeu pour avoir des données sur
lui alors on se dit que c'est un peu
rassurant mais j'ai bien peur qu en
europe ça ça ne fonctionne pas
concernant le respect de la vie privée
et notamment au niveau des enfants ça
peut potentiellement fonctionner aux
états unis potentiellement fonctionner
en asie
pense pas que les lois européennes
permettent qu'on vienne à traquer ses
enfants pour savoir où ils sont a un
instant fait à mon avis ça m'a pas trop
ici l'année dernière apple avait déjà
annoncé un boîtier 100% recyclé en
aluminium et là on est sur du 100%
recyclé au niveau du top ten pour tout
ce qu il être haptique ça c'est pour la
world series 6 il ya une toute nouvelle
monde qui était présente et c'est un peu
la surprise c'est la ouate s es e pour
probablement special edition une watch
un peu moins cher qui crée la surprise
alors cette web elle va tout faire comme
la watch un peu standard notamment
traqué votre activité physique permet
d'avoir toutes vos notifications mais
vous n'aurez pas la possibilité de faire
un de ses jets vous n'aurez pas la
possibilité de connaître votre taux
d'oxygène dans le sang ce qui tourne
avec la puce s5 qui fonctionne déjà très
très bien et qui comportera notamment la
détection de chute pour la prévention
pour les personnes âgées qui tondent hop
ça envoie une alerte et on peut venir
agir à ce moment là voilà pour ces
grosses nouveautés au niveau des appels
watch voulez vous les présente et on en
reparlera ultérieurement si les tests
aura dites moi qu'est ce que vous en
pensez qu est ce que vous pensez de tout
cette question de santé connecter et de
ce que peut faire cette nouvelle watch
series 6
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de la watch
et ce est ce que vous trouvez ça
intéressante qui est in what she moins
cher je vous ai marqué les prix et les
dispos en bas dans la description jusqu
au togo pour me dire ce que vous en
pensez
sur ce je vous embrasse vous en bas
beaucoup d'amour et laure pas très
rapidement de l'apple donc abonnez vous
une fois de plus c'est pas déjà fait à
trévise carlo janka rouge
[Musique]